somewhere between 89 and 93 percent of  black voters vote for Democrats 93  percent voted for Joe Biden based on  exit polls 78 percent of LGBT voters  voted for Biden 71 percent of Jewish  Americans identify as or lean towards  Democratic candidates 66 percent of  Hispanic or Latino voters voted for  Biden 66 percent of Asian American  voters voted for Biden 62 percent of  naturalized citizens uh people like me  voted for Joe Biden 60 percent of those  18 to 29 voted for Joe Biden 59 percent  of disabled voters voted for Joe Biden  55 percent of women okay you're getting  closer and closer to 50 50. diversity  isn't something you do to get it on  record but you go hey we got some Jewish  folks like George Santos oh he's not  Jewish all right cross him off the list  but we've still got more Latino voters  than we've had before it's a reflection  of policy